oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy hello everybody um
i'm just putting this in my discord
which reminds me
russ i don't know if you can create a if
you can have someone on the team create
a garyvee url for discord oh that'd be
good
duster andy if you hear this somebody
can make this if you can make you have
somebody make discord.com i mean uh
what is it garyvee.com or is it
garyvee.com is that my url yeah
i believe so what yes garyvee.com right
slash that's my url time yeah
that's my url garyvee.com
midlifegaryvee.com discord yeah cool
make that
um we got to get that up here for sure
um
but let me go in here if you have a cue
about
live on all platforms oh platforms
um dust and pop in your head a lot of
people miss you from t with garyvee you
should say hello
morning morning morning hello everybody
what have you been up to dust
making tick tock content for you
how's it going um
it goes up and down a lot hurt your
feelings when they flop
um only when you think it's gonna crash
yeah well ice cream mainly when i think
something was like
i thought it was clear enough and then i
didn't lay the context there and i was
like oh crap
um oh people are coming in are you able
to hold them
off before they come on thanks yeah um
all right uh i just uh how quickly
before the garyvee.com
crypto works making it right now discord
30 seconds
awesome thank you uh you got the right
discord
from your uh instagram yeah this would
be great
let me say hello natalie tobias
everybody good to see everybody first
and foremost big shout out to andy k
who has been putting in even more hours
than me
which is unbelievable um
so we're um we are absolutely trying to
uh make the um
the launch happen and i decided to go
live a little bit
just to do two things one as soon as
dustin's done making it there it is oh
you added the five five i like that
um uh so everybody
um please go to this right now if you
have not joined
the discord and you have not um
[Music]
uh downloaded discord yet you're making
a huge mistake so do that right now
garyvee discord get into the discord
leave a comment right now if you're
joining uh if you're about to
um do that if you have not done that
just yet
i'd like to know if you're doing that uh
someone needs my shout out that is
jaren rajadran so he gets that
the discord is awesome and people are
learning about eth
and crypto and wallets dustin you but
you've been learning in there
um or were you a master a little bit no
definitely not a master
uh just got my
eat transferred from coinbase to
metamask but only like
225 dollars worth or whatever that's
right hey i
i don't see i don't want to see any of
this [ __ ] that i see for people like
no i just mean i should have done it
last week but now it's like the weekly
thing so now it's like
but i still have more in my coinbase
still that needs to be transferred
well good news i am i'm announcing here
publicly that i'm going to be gifting
you a coin
yeah we
you deserve it brother um thank you
i love all of you i'm gonna answer a
couple questions real quick and i'm
gonna go back to work
um please join the discord this is the
main reason i'm on right now
it has become a phenomenally good thing
for a lot of people
people are learning truly truly and more
importantly
the project that i'm launching hopefully
tomorrow as some of you been seeing
i'm a little bit not a little bit i'm
actually very concerned that we will not
launch tomorrow on five
i don't know five six or five seven or
five eight has the same ring to it
dustin
[Music]
tech launches are hard man this is big
tech and i need to have it right
so i'm a little worried about that so
i've been bummed a little bit
um for some people it says it doesn't
work so people hit
some people hit the discord and say it
doesn't work and i always wonder what's
going on for
them i think um it happened to me too
when i first
clicked it i think it's because they
either don't have the app installed
on their computer or their phone because
i didn't if you don't have the app
installed it doesn't populate yeah
like it like acted weird like as if like
it's like
this doesn't work here and like your
login doesn't work or something it just
acted kind of
messed up and then once i had to open
the app and then work
hey hey twitch youtube linkedin
facebook i see all of you in here
twitter please um
tick tock take take is to talk in here
uh you can't see them but they can see
us
what's good tiktok um can you please
take the url and
share it in the comments right now with
everybody that's with you
because that is the big point today get
into the discord where there's a ton of
learning
uh and everyone's getting hyped and
ready and and more importantly
the project is 10 255 tokens
the lowest cost tokens start at three
ethereum but they
dutch auction down to 0.5 dustin they go
down to 0.5
but it's a supply and demand game i
don't know if they're going to get down
there
so that's expensive that's a lot that's
a lot of money
there's a lot of coins though but that's
a lot of money and so
there's a lot of people in my community
that don't have that kind of money
uh so i'm gonna be giving away for free
you know after i started seeing i got
you know a lot of people three four
weeks ago
he did my call and bought ethereum dust
so they've done well because ethereum's
got a 50 [ __ ]
percent yeah
um but now people are just getting ready
or they didn't know how to transfer and
they don't have the money in their meta
like you know all the [ __ ] that you have
to learn this is why i did i want people
to learn
so i didn't do fiat so i didn't do it
like nba top shot you can't buy it with
a credit card
my community needs to learn like
non-custodial wallets
and doing cryptocurrency transaction is
going to be life just like putting a
credit card
into a computer was life and i don't
want my community dustin to be like
[ __ ] 45 year olds in
2000 who are like i'm not putting a
credit card in a computer people are
like oh i'm not doing this i'm like you
became your dad
you're your mom remember when you're
like mom put the credit card in the
community it's gonna be okay and she was
like no
you're your [ __ ] mom dust yeah i know
i kept telling myself the same thing
you're your [ __ ] mom justin
so i really wanted to be on chain i
wanted to be very authentic anyway
nonetheless
uh people that are looking for the brian
says he can't find the
i mean colby says i can't find the
discord it's right here cole
garyvee.com discord55
garyvee.com discord55
is the discord blowing up let me go into
the intro see if it's i'd like to see
what's going on with the intro
who came from the live
yeah let's see
here from the live here from live nice
all right coming in
live gang all right nice from twitch
anyway
the discord the reason i'm going live on
all my channels
and please pass it on is the discord is
gonna be the exclusive place that i'm
gonna do
um i'm gonna do
my giveaways because i'm going to stun
people
and give them airdrop
free life yeah understand
i don't think people well i mean
obviously i know more than normal people
but
um i think they're gonna be very
pleasantly surprised
right yeah uh er erie saying link
doesn't work
eerie if the link doesn't work there the
url to the discord is on my
on my instagram and twitter profile
right now
um and uh and
if not um
uh hey dustin we need to put my discord
but link in my twitch bio okay
let's do that um and so
a lot of for a lot of people the link
isn't working for way more it is
i think you have to download discord on
your
the on your ios on your computer
and definitely on your phone that might
help um so we're going to keep educating
keep educated keep educating
um installing discord first may help
the link works i just joined you know
it's working for
tens of thousands so it's working um
and so i'm really excited about this
execution
uh let's ask some questions go ahead
let's bring somebody in
also by the way when you get the discord
um i will never ask for your ethereum
people try to scam in there
i will never ask for your metamask 12
word password
don't trust anybody um if you're dming
with me
and i do dm with people very rarely but
if i do
i'll go on live with you in discord
prove that it's me
so getting that discord all of you
should be in discord anyway in general
like we always do with my community get
in earlier this is not early if they're
gone
discord's been going on gaming community
and all that so anyway
let's do it i'm going to bring on ron
jordan
good hey what's going on garyvee
how are you ron this is incredible i'm
doing great
i'm enjoying the uh the attitude on
discord right now
and enjoying this lifelong dream here of
mine just talking to you really
thank you my man i'm very flattered
where are you from uh from
slippery rock pennsylvania just north of
pittsburgh i know it
it's it's cooking anything i can answer
for you
any statement question actually i do
have a question
um there is a way to throttle back um
to decrease your gas price on metamask
how is that something that we can do in
the auction
is that um will it will lowering that
gas price
it could push us into a situation that
could hurt you yeah we miss out on the
auction
i'm worried about that yes okay uh
yesterday me [ __ ]
dropped do you mind if i take a picture
of this no worries
yesterday me bits dropped and i upped my
gas
thank you man you're welcome uh i upped
my gas to make sure
one of my biggest concerns tomorrow if
god willing or the next day
cardano is amazing aaron but i really
wanted to do this on ethereum
and there's a lot of great chains poca
uh cardano solano there's a lot of cool
stuff going on
um i'm not i'm not uh i'm not stressed i
look exhausted for two reasons one i'm
graying very quickly
two i've always had owl eyes even when i
was like 19
3 yes i definitely have not been
sleeping that much the last couple days
um discord link is working download
discord first
it'll help you um gas
is is what the is the super computers
that are kind of confirming
the fact that you're getting the token
that it's doing the ledger work
i i i think that you know gas will be
expensive tomorrow you know 100
to 150 bucks to be able to just buy
something for
thousands of bucks um so it's not an
inexpensive thing but yes when you're in
the metamask
you have the ability to edit before you
go to do it yeah i
go with fast when i really want
something because when [ __ ] drops
that's what i figured i think i always
thought it's worth the extra 20 30 40
bucks
but i'm also in a luxurious financial
position that i've worked hard my whole
life to be able to afford that swing
um i think a lot of people try to get
cute like people are funny like some of
my friends have
trillions of dollars and they try to do
like the lower gas and miss something
and are pissed i'm like bro you're
buying something for four thousand
dollars
and you're trying to save nineteen
dollars i'm getting extra shipping to
get it this week
that's exactly right so that's my
instagram yeah
tomorrow brother thank you appreciate it
peace
let's keep going
gary what's good bro what's your name
timothy i am i'm i'm yeah i'm 16. it's
it's amazing to talk to you i was not
expecting this today i'm glad we're here
yeah um i kind of realized you were
gonna actually drop an nft really early
on
um i started in the crypto world like a
year or two ago
and um i mean i made a decent little
savings account for myself and uh i
actually dmvu a very long time ago um
which i still haven't really found the
answer to this one question which was um
i i have a choice to make between
either going like i kind of have to drop
high school for a little while
to um be able to manage
the token that me and another uh
colleague of mine created okay
and i i need to make a decision on
whether to go back
or to continue on the path that i'm
going
and it can kind of kind of risk it
it's a it's a decision that i've been
really kind of struggling with for a
while
who are your parents involved in this
decision
um my well i mean currently i am
actually helping with
bills uh both my parents lost their job
during covid
um so i had to kind of step up or at
least i felt like i had to step up and
um
i mean i did um my my parents so it's
your own so it's your own
ideology of bro you can always go to
college
you can go to college at 23.
you will always regret not taking the
risk if you go college
and you can always go to college
right
i i have been it's actually it's
actually the easiest
most practical answer of all time the
only thing you're affected by
is 80 50 60 years of propaganda
of how it's supposed to be done yes
okay you can always go to college after
the risk
probably be 19 and 20 and then nobody's
gonna even [ __ ] know the difference
what do you get it's college it's not
[ __ ] high school
nobody's gonna be weirded out that
you're 20 year old freshman
and if you don't do it you will spend
the rest of your [ __ ] life
wondering what if it's actually the
simplest
decision i've ever seen
i thank you for that i i needed that and
honestly i
i still can't believe i'm talking to you
right now like honestly
um the one thing that i kept thinking
about like as soon as um
i was actually at church when somebody
told me about your account
real quick everyone everyone's talking
about
high school ever because you know
so you're talking about getting a high
school degree
yeah watch this high school two
see what's funny is everyone has crossed
the chasm
of oh right you know 20 years ago
they're like no college
now half the audience in here is like oh
yeah yeah college
but the thought of high school is like
no
nothing will ever happen if you don't
get a high school degree
as if it's some [ __ ] other thing like
it's all the same [ __ ]
out here you can always go back to high
school too get a g
like by the way a high school degree is
not some
profound thing that's going to change
your outcome
come on people oh this [ __ ]
[ __ ] as if a high school degree what
does everybody in here want oh
i got a high school degree now i can get
the big job at [ __ ] walmart get the
[ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] enough
listen it'd be nice it's nice like but
like i don't know like
come on um
there's uh i've always i don't even want
it like
like like you know what's so fun funny
some people should graduate
high school is anybody watching this and
thinks this kid
can't navigate life without a high
school degree
is that any you know like when i answer
i answer to the person i'm talking to
nothing i talk about is for everybody
let me tell you one thing i have seen
school do more damage to people
than bring value people that are
religious about school become very
anxious
grown-ups they think that they conform
to the system
somebody's always above them judging
them grading them they're always waiting
for their
next race cycle as if they're trying to
get an a or b in [ __ ] school
it's enough with the education is the
most important thing in the world
the way we [ __ ] package and operate
it and sell it
in america especially is some [ __ ]
[ __ ] well i mean honestly it's more of a
they're uh creating you to be a worker
for them
rather than be somebody on your own it's
you know what's so funny it's not even
some master system like that anymore
it's just that like the internet exists
yeah like you're getting educated these
are different kids
i mean i've learned we gotta we gotta we
gotta unschool these kids of course you
learn more on google bro i couldn't i
couldn't
spell or like i didn't even know words
of course i i want to ask you one
question
um i have been
like trying my hardest to speak to you
for like so long like it'll
be like a year most likely uh
i even tried dme one time every single
day for like a month to see if you'd
ever reply
oh so sorry bro i'm trying so hard you
can't even imagine between the text
between the discord between dms between
real life
like i'm really trying and i get to so
many
and i used to get a lot of credit for in
2007 to 11 because i was able to get to
everybody
now i get to
70 of what i used to the problem is
that's only one percent of the overall
request so i apologize to you and
everybody who's watching i'm really
really trying in a way that i think is
so different than most
it's just the math the overwhelming math
the demand is just too big
so i i know that i've well
i've gotten somewhere right but i
don't know more like kind of where to go
from here
um i need kind of somebody to
or something to kind of guide you
guide me i was wondering and
hoping to ask you if you have any type
of internship opportunities
dwight uh dustin have this kid talk to
dwayne
on our on on the uh he's new he's in
aj's world get into aj's world
all right cool there you go brother
you get your shot thank you so
much yeah you you have no idea this is
absolutely amazing hi
timothy make sure you uh dm me so like
i know who you are okay um i'll connect
everything
okay uh do you want me is that instagram
or
yeah at dustin not justin
you see him uh while they're doing that
everyone
please share the garyvee.com discord55
in the chat that you're in right now
twitch instagram
linkedin twitter uh to have people join
us they'll get educated
and uh and then it's amazing what's
going on in discord right now it's just
amazing
for some of you it's not working uh but
if you download the app first it will
um if you download if i leave here in
one minute because i have a meeting
which is
true uh if you if you go to my
instagram or twitter account the discord
url
is in the bio
thank you timpy thank you very much um
that was uh it said he said add dustin
correct
is it just that nope i went he wishes he
had that dustin
doesn't kiss he's like didn't you guys
talk offline here behind
yeah yeah okay yeah i'll i'll press
enter
you guys can talk human thank you very
much you're right not everything has to
be computer dustin
remember it's always both it's not or
yes yes yes
yes right brother don't please so much
just stay back here
no worries brother thank you so much
you're welcome you're welcome
um please join the discord uh updates
uh get your metamasks for your
non-custodial wallets anything that's
compatible with
wallet connect a lot of this is foreign
this is why i want you to go into
discord
many of you will not be destined to be
able to get one of my tokens tomorrow
many of you
can't afford it and that pulls up my
heartstrings and thus
i need to give some away many away i
will give many away
in the discord only in the discord which
is why i'm going on live on all my
channels right now
and making sure everybody goes um
to the discord becomes part of the
discord mainly
because the friendships that are being
made there and the education
that is happening there is more
important
than you buying my token
that means i have to go to my next
meeting because i knew i'd be hyped in
here
please share this discord um
my coin my it's not a coin it's an nft
everything will be announced fully
tomorrow
um do not do not follow whatever
this coin see there's a fake thing going
on in facebook i will never ask you for
ethereum
i will never ask you for ethereum i will
never ask you for ethereum
this [ __ ] [ __ ] scammer on
facebook right now asking to send your
wallet
thank you for blocking it [ __ ]
they're just bad bad bad people
i will never ask you for ethereum i will
never ask you for your meta mask
password i will never ask i will never
ask i will never ask
uh um dustin i sent you
a video that i would like you to play
for everybody right now yeah
please watch this everybody because i
think people are confused of how long i
listen and watch and think this video is
from 2017.
the link doesn't work for some people
download discord
or go to my instagram or facebook
twitter account and click it
i'm sure you can figure it out it's so
much bigger than people 27 people talk
about
bitcoin but you know once you start
understanding what blockchain dynamics
mean
this is going to change the way our
entire society lives over the next 20 30
years
it's worth your four hours on a beach
one day to get educated
on blockchain and ethereum and where
we're going this is how you're gonna
this is how wills are gonna be done this
is how contracts are gonna be done this
is how everything is going to be done so
get educated
you see that listen 2017
people are like yeah i remember i was
re-watching the
nipsy hustle interview you had with him
and you were talking about ethereum with
like one of his
friends i was like
dustin i just sent it to you share it
share it i want people to understand
what the [ __ ] i'm on
they think i'm flying are you doing are
you [ __ ] around blockchain yet
people don't understand people do not
understand
share it
2017 life
are you [ __ ] around blockchain yet
yeah you enjoying that
you hacking on top of ethereum yet no
yeah but but it's caught your eye right
yeah that shit's gonna be [ __ ]
you right you right see ya